[Music]
one of the reasons that the stock market
has been on such a tear over the past
five years or so is that debt has been
relatively cheap
people have been able to go to the bank
borrow money and invest that in the
stock market with the promise that the
stock market would generate higher
returns the problem is that inflation
has encouraged central banks to increase
interest rates in the hope of reducing
prices we can see here the effect that
has had on debt here in the middle of
2020 the yields or the interest provided
by u.s bonds
was near half a percent in the space of
just a month or two that has jumped to
three percent that means it's harder to
borrow money and spend it on the stock
market we can see the effect that that
has had on stocks particularly meme
stocks these companies that had a really
good lock down from an investment
perspective have lost in some instances
three quarters their value in the space
of just three months the likes of
kavanagh roblox and coinbase the point
of comparison according to the bloomberg
opinion columnist john authors is the
tech bubble of the year 2000.
back then the difference in valuation
between tech stocks and
the rest of the market had broadened and
spread in the year 2021 and 2022 the
difference between tech stocks and the
rest of the market was at a similar
level there has been a bit of a
correction but if the lessons of the
millennium met anything to go by there
may still be some way to go